[Music]
we have previously done a video on the
timeline and the life story of Kong and
the monsterverse now we will do the same
with titanis Gojira not the members of
his species but just him solely as he is
the main character of this universe we
have taken out the red Ki namura and the
timeline associated with it and then
added other things to be up to date with
the current setting so let's get to it
prehistory Godzilla and marra defeat
gdor for the first time in Antarctica as
was seen in the cave paintings Godzilla
and His Kind were worship and then had
an underground city built for them with
monuments and murals the city would
subside underwat for reasons unknown and
was seen in the king of the monsters
movie before 10,000 BC the last is was
triggered due to the Titan war in the
hollow Earth that Godzilla was a part of
and also shimu is now suspected to to be
the cause of the Ice Age and also the
one behind the freezing of gidora in the
Antarctic Ice before 10,000 BC Godzilla
was defeated by a rival Kong that took
his layer from him as was seen in the
flashbacks in the comics of Godzilla
Dominion this Kong isn't the same one we
know in the present day between 10,000
BC and 1945 due to the cataclysm and the
Ice Age Godzilla and the other Titans
undergo periods of hibernation and he
wakes up from time to time to check on
them
1945 Godzilla gets awakened by the
atomic bombings in Hiroshima and
Nagasaki although this timeline along
with shinamura has been redon the
Awakening part from Slumber still holds
strong due to the fact that Godzilla is
always connected to those fateful
events 1954 Godzilla was led to the
bikini atols by the US Military and the
Castle Bravo nuclear test was conducted
as a disguise with a main aim of killing
the Titan the most powerful nuclear
explosion conducted by the us served
only as an appetizer to the
Gman 1955 Godzilla resurfaces again in
the Japanese islands of hauma which were
also called Monster Island he was led
back up to the surface World by an
experimental gar Ray device developed by
Dr Suzuki 1959 two possible Godzilla
sightings occur one is on March 15 when
an unknown underwater creature is
captured on Sonar and the other is at
another point in the year when a large
creature is photographed in the ocean
thanks to a
satellite 197 3 Monarch on the Houston
Brooks would Breathe James Conrad on the
existence of other Titans on the planet
and Godzilla being inferred to be active
and
abound
2014 Godzilla senses the emergence of
the mutos and would pursue them around
the world he would confront the male
Muto in Hawaii Furs and then this
Pursuit would end in the Battle of San
Francisco where he would kill both the
male and a female
mutos late
2014 Godzilla balanced a Muto prime a
predatory species that hunts and lays
eggs on the bodies of dead goeras
Godzilla defeated in Montana but not
before getting his ass kicked and dorsal
plates shattered which would eventually
grow back 2015 Godzilla was discovered
to be resting and recuperating in the
middle of the desert in Algeria where he
emerged from under a mountain of dirt in
his kotm doig Goji form he was
subsequently disappear again in the
desert probably entering a hollow Earth
Vortex point two
2017 Godzilla enters the AIS Mundi drawn
by the gamma ray device and in that Dark
Realm he would battle and kill the Iron
Dragon which puts up a short but vicious
fight between 2017 and
2019 Godzilla was stated to be swimming
around the world and especially to
Antarctica to check on gidora who is
still stuck in ice and also to scal
Island to check on Kong about him being
still in his territory between 2017 and
2019 a reptilian tan the size of a large
whale was found dead in the Arctic as
Mark Yer died in the sea and was
mentioned that it had Scorch marks on
her scales this makes Godzilla the
culprit
2019 the events of king of the monsters
and The Awakening of the tirant they
take place in this year where Godzilla
also fights gdar three times firstly in
Antarctica where gdar flees the fight
and then in the middle of the sea
outside of Mexico and finally in Boston
where with the help of M he transforms
into his burning form and annihilates
the three-headed dragon also in 2019
while searching for a place to rest in
the ocean titanis Naka was poisoned and
captured in an electrified net Godzilla
saves Naka from her captivity and kills
the
perpetrators between 2019 and 2021
Godzilla keeps a check on the activity
of the surface World Titans stopping
Sila from attacking ships stopping
amhuluk from invading the Amazon and
killing behemoth and then battling the
genitor Swarm finally resting after
defeating Tiamat and retaking his old
layer that he lost to the Rival Kong way
back in the past this Kong Lost that
layer to Tiamat which in turn lost it to
Godzilla again so the cycle
continues between 2023 to
2024 Godzilla starts to become more
aggressive and attacks Apex facilities
all around the world culminating in the
attack at Pensacola it is later found
that the Apex facilities were
experimenting with gora's skulls and
organs thereby releasing a bioacoustic
signature of gidora that triggered
Godzilla 2024 Godzilla battles with Kong
in the Tasman Sea sparing The Big Ape
when the ships turn off their engines as
a sign of submission he would then fight
Kong again in Hong Kong and then Bal mea
Godzilla after that nearly getting
killed if not for the timely
intervention of Kong so these are the
GVK events between 2024 and
2025 after a Godzilla and Kong makes
their peace Godzilla rules Supreme Over
the surface World while Kong is sent
back to the hollow Earth to claim it as
his home to search for remaining members
of his species between 2025 and 2028 in
the events of gxk the hunted for some
unknown reason godilla senses something
wrong and attacks an oil rig in the
middle of the ocean probably trying to
prevent another human Titan encounter or
senses the presence of a Sinister threat
again between 2025 and 20 28 Godzilla
battles an arachnet Titan in Rome and
rest in the middle of the Coliseum it is
unknown yet if this battle immediately
precedes the rest of the events of gxk
or it might be something that happens
quite a few years before
2028 Godzilla will evolve into his pink
form with the crystalline dorsal plates
and the tail thiza he would also come
out of the ice crysters with a leaner
body and longer arms this form will be
called the evolved
Godzilla also in 20 2028 Godzilla would
have to team up with K and other Titans
to deal with the threat of scaring shimu
and an army of Hollow Earth Kongs
thereby triggering the events of gxk the
new
Empire so that's all we have about
Godzilla in brief as of the current
setting now if you like this video then
watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other
monsterverse contents we might just have
things you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam